[Música]
considere la siguiente oración este
enunciado es falso eso es verdadero en
ese caso la declaración sería falsa pero
si es falso la declaración es verdadera
al referirse a sí misma esta declaración
Crea una paradoja irresoluble pero si no
es verdadera ni falsa Qué es la pregunta
parece un experimento mental absurdo
pero a inicio del siglo XX llevó al
lógico austriaco kur goodle a descubrir
algo que cambiaría las matemáticas para
siempre el descubrimiento exploraba las
limitaciones de las pruebas matemáticas
una prueba es un argumento lógico cuyo
fin es demostrar por una afirmación
numérica es verdadera los bloques que
forman estos argumentos se conocen como
axiomas proposiciones innegables sobre
los números involucrados todos los
sistemas basados en matemáticas desde la
comprobación más compleja hasta la
aritmética
se construyen a partir de
axiomas Y si una declaración sobre
ciertos números es verdadera los
matemáticos pueden confirmarla con una
prueba
axiomática desde la antigua Grecia los
matemáticos usaron este sistema para
probar o refutar afirmaciones
matemáticas con
certeza pero Cuando gole entró al campo
algunas nuevas paradojas lógicas estaban
amenazando esa
certeza los grandes matemáticos estaban
ansiosos por probar que las matem no
tenían contradicciones gole no estaba
tan seguro estaba menos seguro de que
las matemáticas fueran la herramienta
adecuada para investigar este problema
Aunque es relativamente fácil crear una
paradoja autorreferencial con palabras
los números no suelen hablar de ellos
mismos una declaración matemática
simplemente puede ser verdadera o falsa
pero guru tuvo una idea primero tradujo
declaraciones matemáticas y ecuaciones a
números en un código para que una idea
matemática compleja pudiera expresarse
con solo un número esto significó que
los enunciados escritos con esos números
También expresaban algo sobre los
enunciados
codificados así las codificaciones
ayudarían a las matemáticas a hablar de
sí mismas a través de este método pudo
escribir esta declaración no se puede
probar como una ecuación creando así la
primera declaración matemática
autorreferencial Sin embargo a
diferencia de la oración ambigua que lo
inspiró los enunciados matemáticos deben
ser verdaderos o falsos Entonces qué es
si es falso eso significa que la
declaración tiene una prueba pero si un
enunciado matemático tiene una prueba
Entonces debe ser verdadero esta
contradicción significa que la
declaración de gole no puede ser falsa y
por tanto debe ser cierto que esta
declaración no puede ser
probada sin embargo este resultado es
aún más sorprendente porque significa
que ahora tenemos una verdad ecuación
matemática que afirma que no se puede
probar esta revelación está en el
corazón del teorema de incompletitud de
gole que introduce una clase totalmente
nueva de enunciados matemáticos en el
paradigma de gole los enunciados siguen
siendo verdaderos o falsos pero los
enunciados verdaderos pueden ser
demostrables o indemostrables dentro de
un conjunto dado de
acciom además G argumentaba que estas
declaraciones verdaderas
existen en todos los sistemas
axiomáticos esto vuelve imposible el
crear un sistema perfectamente completo
usando matemáticas porque siempre habrá
enunciados verdaderos que no podremos
probar aunque tenga en cuenta estas
declaraciones indemostrables al
agregarlas como nuevos axiomas a un
sistema matemático ampliado ese mismo
proceso introduce nuevas afirmaciones
verdaderas indemostrables
sin importar Cuántos axiomas agregue
siempre habrá declaraciones verdaderas
que no no se podrán probar Siempre será
gurle hasta el
final Este descubrimiento sacudió los
cimientos de las Matemáticas y destruyó
a los que soñaban que todas las
afirmaciones matemáticas algún día
serían probadas O refutadas aunque
muchos aceptaron la nueva realidad otros
matemáticos la refutaron y otros
intentaron ignorarla pero cuando se
probaron problemas clásicos como
indemostrables ya que sus trabajos nunca
Se podrían completar aún así el teorema
de Google abrió muchas puertas el saber
de la indecidibilidad en declaraciones
verdaderas inspiró innovaciones claves
en las primeras computadoras y hasta el
día de hoy algunos matemáticos dedican
sus carreras a identificar enunciados
demostrables e indemostrables así aunque
los matemáticos perdieron algo de
certeza gracias a gole pueden aceptar la
incertidumbre que se encuentra en
cualquier búsqueda de la
verdad
le interesa la historia de las
Matemáticas mire este video para
aprender sobre el mejor matemático que
nunca vivió mantenga viva la
[Música]
curiosidad